you know I didn't want to go away from
the spirit of the play and but the play
had a lot of elements that would never
have translated to the screen they had a
narrator who literally talked you
through every plot point that did or
didn't make sense sherry got gets off
the bus in the beginning of the play
literally looking like a five dollar
hooker and then sleeps with Stacee Jaxx
so that became a very difficult
relationship to root for for the movie
so there was a lot of things that we had
to do to tonally make it more this I
know this gonna sound really weird more
real you know because it was very very
Winky the show and people like that but
it works when you don't have to do
close-ups Adam here was you know the
callous behind every song that's enough
but you know he'd come to me what about
this idea what about this idea i mean
just like a machine of ideas spewing
forth at all times I mean there's
examples of we just finished jukebox
hero and he has a dream the dream is
that I love rock and roll is in jukebox
hero and he goes will this work and like
rap so we had to do that again but you
know I don't think it'll catalyst for
that was that there was the word jukebox
in both songs that's how thin my
reasoning is yeah and that makes perfect
sense musically so I had to figure that
out I things a lot of that organically
you know things come up as you're trying
to move a story forward you know and
he's trying to and you have this huge
catalogue of songs to pull from which is
great the 80s I mean it's there's so
many good songs there was that just so
you know the reason that that those two
numbers are actually in there and those
two numbers came in very late in the
game during they were not in there until
a couple months before we started right
like two weeks before we stir it all the
way oops it was because I actually paged
I read through the script finally no I
read I I was going through the script
and I realized after the first number
there were 20 pages between that and the
nexts and the second song and it was 20
pages of setup and I went berserk
because I was like that the movie can't
handle that like and then I realized
that drew it would be more interesting
for Drew to sing his backstory than two
talk about it endlessly it for God's
sakes it's musicals but then you working
with people at Tom Cruise who'd never
sung much less than a musical I mean you
can't count you know Top Gun as his it's
not really a musical but you know so he
was like you know it son the guy's
unbelievable I mean the work he put in
which is kind of what as a producer you
dream of really to have people like that
they're willing to go there and to do
whatever you ask you know he was willing
to do it and even for me to say like
that sound you just made don't ever do
that again and he's a cool good good
feedback let's go you know he's just
awesome you know and that's what you
want just she's receptive everything so
it was just an amazing experience really
on all fronts when I told him originally
we first scouted the movie we went to
Sydney Australia he's like are you
kidding me I'm going to Sydney Australia
for a movie that takes place in my
backyard somewhere I grew up in I'm like
yeah we gotta try and make it work so
let's uh let's continue do you know keep
Forge I like Sydney but it looked like
San Diego it does Sydney looks like San
Diego and I was like oh but at least
there's palm trees there well the palm
trees they're actually look like
pineapples so it was weird it ended up
being I did say Anders key do Glee from
Australia no so find a place that had
the right architecture and the structure
infrastructure for us to you know really
recreate Sunset Strip which was a
character in the movie was our biggest
challenge in Florida you know my knee
Beach particularly offered that we're
not only could we find the Sunset Strip
there but other locations like Venice
Beach that were you know a very easy
match for us and that was something that
made it very easy forest accomplished
and it was just fantastic it was dream
to watch so is you know watch them
transform these actors are never saying
before turning them into you know coin
artists was a pretty impressive Alec and
Russell recorded I can't fight this
feeling anymore at the same time in
booth singing to each other we made sure
they could see each other and he made
sure we so they were like literally hear
that home video yeah he put his iphone
shooting the whole thing it was so crazy
hilarious priceless I know if finding
the voice of each character with these
actors was just so much fun you know Tom
Mary J you know she's an RB singer and
she's the hugest 80s fan you know music
which is really cool Julian's a country
singer naturally finding her rock voice
Diego's a pop singer and you know it
just it was just such a cool experience
just seeing these kids transform or even
non kids he was sorry he was strict
though like you know there are times
where he actually said things that I
probably wouldn't I mean I'm I make fun
of like when like sometimes like Tom
would be so crazy i would go let's do it
one more time but this time couldn't you
be good and reckon he would laugh and
then we do it again so but but he would
get like really strict with them and go
and he said never ever make that sound
again if please I'm begging you you know
and you know so it's a very humbling
experience for the cast being on this
because you do not get to phone it in
there's no option to phoned in because
you have to work so hard